i was so drunk yesterday i was texting
dana a bunch i was like yo like
let's get akashi 69 tickets
[Laughter]
dude check it out he texts me the other
day steve will do it texts me he goes yo
dude can i facetime you real quick for
my vlog and i said [ __ ] yeah you can
so i pick up the facetime call and it's
him sitting there with tekashi69
and i'm like no way dude six nine
i did a tattoo of you on someone and i
[ __ ] texted it to
[Music]
and then like after after this
conversation i hung up later right and i
thought man i'm gonna be on steve will
do its vlog
like with six nine and i wonder like i
wonder like
if if that's gonna be something that
comes with the backlash because i've
seen people have
backlashes for associating themselves
with six
nine and i was like you know what [ __ ]
it i don't care i was stoked
i was stuck yeah what are the backlashes
from
this there was an nfl player i saw him
on tmz and he had like he brought like
six
nine to his like workout like something
or other and all the people were like
dude dude
you know like you're done you can't hang
out with him why because he's ratted on
people
yeah now here's what i think about
ratting right
anybody in that situation
is going to rat like whether you're
talking about what you're going to spend
like
30 years and he he was facing 69 years
69 was facing 69 years like were you
gonna go to prison for 69 years for your
your reputation you know no dude like
anybody's going to be a rat and if you
don't want to be a rat then like maybe
don't commit crime
that's like my deal you know like we're
we're 12-step guys so like we're like
pretty careful about not like
screwing people over like doing the
wrong thing you know like
we like we probably aren't going to have
to rat on anybody because we're probably
not going to be facing a lot of prison
time
exactly yeah what what were you guys
doing on the vlog
no we i don't know if i could talk about
this yeah you don't
you don't have to if you feel like that
no but i mean we'll talk about it
and and and he felt strongly that like
he's put it out there hanging out with
six nine and gotten
zero zero zero hate because uh because
he's a nice guy
that was that's the thing six nights the
sweetest of guys that's right and he was
really cool to me on the facetime call
too he was like oh dude stevo you're a
legend like he was really
said nice things and was uh were you
guys were you
can you talk about where you guys were
we're in cabo and
um yeah we're just kaba we're hanging
out because we we became
good friends recently but anyways the
inaugural catfish
right sure yeah so there's a girl that
thinks she's in love with me now right
all that so uh neve wanted to facetime
me
and um about this girl named diamond
and she thinks she's in love with me so
that's what we were doing in mexico
we're just
facetiming neve and gambling what's the
six nine tie in there
six times see things i grew up listening
to him in the gym
and like out and the thing was the thing
is about me is i was always promoting
six
nine and i was like when i was like i
was broke with zero dollars and [ __ ]
whatever and i was like i was posting on
instagram it was like it was like
[ __ ] you i literally post the captions
like [ __ ] you guys like
i don't give a [ __ ] if you guys don't
like six nine but when i'm in the gym i
listen to six nine so i love this guy
i remember that so so so for me to be
posting that [ __ ]
and then me being like best buddies with
him now it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] with no no i like to
take that stance too man you know like i
like to be more of a dana white type
person if anybody has a [ __ ] problem
then
[ __ ] off but that's what i'm saying like
like for me like i
grew up and i loved his music like
i listened to six nine through what's
[ __ ] sixteen
thousand sixteen thousand bench press
sets you know i'm saying it's like
i'm not gonna change you know it's like
i'm not gonna change up on him now
just because like right he did he did
something that the result was
he was not in jail like i'm not gonna
change up on him sure i
saw his uh he like shattered records
doing an instagram live
like when he yeah when he got
right and on that instagram live he was
saying like wow dude these
are what i'm going to be loyal to these
people how the [ __ ] were they loyal to
me
you know he was uh he said these guys
kidnapped me they pistol with me like
what i was going to protect them and
like
go to prison for them they weren't loyal
to me and yeah if if that's all true
it's like
why would you right right and even if
it's not true
like if and i'm telling you anybody
who's facing that much prison time
is gonna cooperate to to not go to
prison like that's just human nature
it's like
oh [ __ ] yeah like shotgun
with a poop cannon yeah yeah my [ __ ]
you're never gonna do that again huh i'm
never gonna do that again dude
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man
because it's gnarly and it's all the
stuff i wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats